[Musique]
l'émission pour mois de l'année ce sera
sans doute ce qui a bouleversé le climat
politique en france c'est le duo entre
marine le pen
emmanuel macron avant la présidentielle
que là tout a basculé franchement nous
sommes allés voir vieilles canailles
ensemble hier soir le code de l'année
c'est difficile parce que chacun à
plusieurs couacs en fait vous savez il
ya toujours cette course à l'information
à la rapidité à oskou peu au buzz et
dont je crois que tout le monde même les
chaînes infos à certaines chaînes info
mais tout le monde peut succomber à
cette à ce besoin de sortir le scoop en
premier ou le buzz même sais pas si j'ai
de virer le plus gros buzz de l'année je
dirais plutôt la main la plus grande
farce de l'année c'est l'élection donald
trump le plus beau moment de l'année
c'est celui que je vais vivre demain
aujourd'hui
je sais pas si je peux parler des
meilleurs souvenirs d'un thé pmt souffre
de payer en tout cas c'est qu'à chaque
fois il nous pousse dans les plus
grandes en ce moment chaque fois cyril
nous pousse à aller plus loin à l'est de
façon authentique parfois parfois dire
des choses qui peuvent dépasser notre
temps c'est ce qui fait ils demandent
parfois ça crée des problèmes
moi je sais que je n'aime pas avoir de
problème je ne suis pas un homme de
conflit mais en revanche j'avoue qu'à
chaque fois quand ils nous poussent à
dire les choses dire le fond de notre
pensée après touba fois ci mais pourquoi
pas daniel moreau c'est ma petit cochon
sur bernard je sais pas si c'est le
meilleur chroniqueur en tout cas c'est
le plus gaga c'est verdez tapper d'orgue
une balance tout et vous même changé où
je vous donnerais une note sévère la
voilà castaldi c'est un cadeau si tu
veux rester chroniqueur longtemps chez
cyril hanouna d'intérêt est très fort et
a bien dégagée parce que parce qu'il ya
de la demande
quoi qu'il en soit et il faut
s'accrocher parce que c'est très
difficile d'y rester
croyez moi moi je vais arriver bien
repart bien voilà c'est comme ça c'est
bien comme ça